I thought that was my chair?
I think this is my better side.
All right Ana, what drew you to the film?
I wanted to work with you again.
Me.
Yes, it's true. It's true.
But in a very different capacity.
Like I knew as soon as I read it
that you and I were going to have a blast.
Yeah, this is my third collaboration with the lovely de Armas.
This is actually the first time we get along.
You know, we've been adversaries for the other films.
So finally, her and I actually get to work together.
Like each other a little bit more.
Yeah.
Eventually.
Eventually, we get there.
Who are you?
CIA.
So Sadie,
she's this incredible secret agent, and she meets Cole.
And there's something in Cole that,
she's never seen before.
You know, this very weird, clumsy...
- Charming, magnetic
- Unfortunate
- Irresistible magnetism.
- Clearly.
Well, I was just wondering if you wanted to, um,
you know, go out sometime.
Are you serious?
I get what your saying though, there's
something refreshingly honest about Cole,
you know, albeit a little clumsy.
I swallowed a rock!
But they have this really nice meeting.
They have this great date.
And then Sadie ghosts him.
And I don't think Cole deserved it.
I mean, he was obviously a little too enthusiastic.
- He kind of couldn't read the room
- Just a little.
I bet she hasn't even seen your texts.
Yeah, yeah.
Go to her.
I'm going to London.
Just a little.
But, you know, she obviously had bigger fish to fry.
She had a lot going on.
I was working.
There really are so many great action
set pieces, whether it's the bus,
or the plane, or the rotating restaurant.
Are you ready?
Ready for what?
No! I’m not!
I’m definitely not!
That scene in the restaurant,
was really a challenge
because it was a really big space.
Yeah, that was one of the few scenes
that we really got to have with Adrien.
What a romantic spot for our first official date.
Adrien is such a great energy on set.
He's so good and so funny.
I met Adrien in a very different movie.
And all of a sudden I see Adrien with this mustache,
and french accent.
What do you go for? Huh?
A fairy tale?
Fairly tales are for children!
Cut!
It was really really challenging.
I think probably the most difficult scene.
- And of course, I was like in this dress
- You were in high heels
- and the dress. the hair...woosh.
- And the heels, and...
Yeah.
And the difficulty of, you know, once
this thing gets out of control and
starts spinning faster and faster.
Acting velocity.
Acting. the...
the gravity, and the pressure, it was just really really hard.
You look amazing in that dress.
And you should wear more suits.
I really do think this is something
that is going to be for everyone,
you know, because it does
have this marriage of comedy and
action and romance and drama.
I mean, it checks all those boxes
and it's one of those movies
that I grew up on that I love dearly
that, that I just don't see enough.
I feel like it is relevant in today's world.
And honestly, how do people meet each other?
Don’t ask me!
I can barely use my phone.
And I'm pretty sure there's a lot of texting involved.
Truely, yeah.
There a lot of emojis.
Emoji stuff doesn't count.
Yes, it does.
Emoji stuff counts.
Hopefully for everyone out there
who's been ghosted it will give them
the belief that maybe they were ghosted
because the person was a super spy.
I have never been ghosted.
Really?
It's not true.
I mean, I admire your confidence, especially
if she's the one who ghosted ya.
No, no, she didn't ghost me.
She just doesn't have an international calling plan.
Oh, right.
An international art curator
doesn't have an overseas calling plan.
That's very unusual.